I forget who I've had a few people do
that with me like just in conversation
and I feel like you were involved
somehow because I've met you before
uh somewhere yeah I don't know if we
were or you were just parties together
oh maybe it was just like a bunch of
people that kind of
play with the same or like the circling
it's just a practice explicitly
dedicated towards that what circling
circling things that might be the thing
yeah I think I think so we know we have
some mutual circulars in our circles in
our networks here what's uh what's
circling I don't I remember I'm gonna
describe it horribly because it's like
one of those things that's difficult to
describe unless you experience it like
kind of like drugs yeah but it's
something like you sit around there's
like kind of guidelines to the
conversation where you talk about the
present moment yeah you're like honest
about your experiences as much as you
can be and if you don't want to be
honest then you say I don't want to be
honest
um and your like commitment to
connection so like you're here to like
actually connect with the other person
understand them and be understood yeah
um you're not supposed to like project
so if you're like have an analysis about
the other person you own it you're like
I'm experiencing you as this you know
and then you check is it true
um or like are you are you supposed to
be almost like converting it towards the
thing you're thinking like constantly
um if it feels right in the moment you
can the thing is it's very amorphous
right it's like almost like creating a
magical sensation and I've been with
some I've seen some very good circulars
really high skill Circle and I feel like
I'm on drugs when that happens it's very
rare to see
does it feel honest somehow yeah very
honest
like like right now in this moment I'm
feeling like kind of like nervous energy
because I'm talking to you and this is a
unique situation and like I want you to
think I'm cool yeah I want everybody
listed me to think I'm cool but I'm also
having some sort of delight at being
able to express in this way and like
some admiration for how you like set up
and built this thing that I can be a
part of and all of these things are sort
of in my body right now is this sort of
vibrating High thing I remember like in
the party setting because I've got to
talk to a few people I felt like it was
going sexual very quickly
okay I don't know if you remember this
but the first time I met you I didn't
know who you were I just heard I knew
I'd heard your name like here's your
name and like I think I've heard people
discuss that sure and I was in the
middle of a very sexual conversation
with another woman oh you were yeah I
was and you just like turned around and
left very shortly afterwards and I
thought it was right oh was I listening
in on the conversation or something it
was like it was like I was talking to
her and you were just kind of like right
there and so we introduced ourselves and
then we continued on with the
conversation and you were like standing
there and listening yeah and then I
don't think I would have left the cut so
it's funny you probably interpret it in
a different way
as you like not wanting to listen to
like graphic sexual stuff was it like
super graphic I don't know I was I was
asking her about I was doing I was
interviewing her about her fetish
basically oh yeah I don't think I would
have walked away from that I would have
been like Curious oh interesting because
I don't often see people having a deep
interview about fetishes like I wouldn't
even be listen I'm like Jane Goodall
here like I'm not like
I'm not afraid of sexuality or something
like that I just have certain values in
terms of like monogamy and so on but I
think okay sexuality is really beautiful
yeah I I don't think
yeah I can't imagine myself walking away
from that conversation he was somebody
must have like called you or something
because I didn't remember exactly how it
worked I just remember thinking later on
or maybe I thought I was intruding oh
maybe because if I was kind of drunk so
you know I probably was very okay
I would like to actually have like
footage of that conversation so we can
actually interpret what actually
happened because it's probably I mean
you know the human interactions are are
funny like that they could
they can help for all kinds of reasons